well let's uh bring in the mayor of
greater manchester should we andy
burnham who joins us now hello to you mr
burnham thanks for joining us on the
programme this morning let's start with
that uh 20 pounds uplift that's going to
be taken away from people uh in the form
of universal credit your thoughts on
that
it's just the wrong thing to do you know
we've just heard haven't we the uh the
impact it will have on people and let's
be honest kate you know there's a lot of
uh recovery that people will have to
make from from the pandemic people not
in the position i i don't think uh to
take a hit like this right now and in
fact i would say it should be just left
because many people it's forgotten this
many people on universal credit are in
work and it's just because their wages
are so low or they're on zero hours
contracts that their their earnings
won't won't give them enough to live on
this is where we've got to uh as a
country and i think we've got to get to
a situation where everyone has a basic
income that gives them enough money to
live on without actually turning to the
benefit system but until we get to that
point absolutely universal credit needs
to be kept at this current uplifted rate
uh and then we build from there to
create a fairer long-term solution
i want to talk to you about social care
as well of course and how that should be
paid for we're going to be hearing
hopefully from the prime minister
promised two years ago hopefully we'll
hear later on this week how he plans to
pay for social care for the elderly um
labor have said we don't want to see an
increase in national insurance but not
really coming up with another option
well it's good actually to be fair that
the government are gripping this issue
because as we know okay it goes back a
long way and successive governments have
failed to grip it so let's put a tick in
the box there
but if you wanted to think of the most
unfair way of funding social care then
national insurance would be it because
it's paid by very low low paid uh
workers younger people
and it isn't paid by the older the older
generation because it stops at
retirement age so really you know you
couldn't think of a worse way of doing
this in my view we should not be taxing
work we should be taxing wealth uh to
pay for the reform of of social care
because you know it's that generation if
i can say it put it this way okay it's
my mum and dad's generation who are who
are coming to the point now where maybe
they might need the care system at some
point but they didn't pay through their
taxes through their working life for
social care because social care wasn't
in
in the post-war settlement if you like
so you you can't ask younger workers
today you know we would call them
generation rent wouldn't we people
who've got big uh student debt
you can't ask that generation to pay for
the care of a generation who've not
contributed through the tax system that
that isn't right i would say ask all
older people through the assets they've
got the property assets to make a
contribution the beneficiary should make
a contribution but then turn to other
wealth taxes like capital gains tax to
make up the difference that i think is
the basis for a fair funding solution
well we're waiting for kia stammer to
say that but he's not said that at the
moment although as you know the tuc has
suggested that as a way forward um i
wonder if i could finish with this a
report last week uh by
labour in communications urged uh
kyostama to slim down the shadow cabinet
apparently and give a more prominent
role to well-respected labour leaders
from around the country
we're looking at you um would you answer
the call if asked
well i think the benefit i can bring is
to speak more independently because
that's the
the great joy of a mayoral role okay i
don't have to you know follow the ins
and outs of what's going on in
westminster but if i'm honest on this
issue of social care you know i put
forward a plan 10 years ago for a
national care service and i'm still
arguing for that now and i think maybe
that will help the labour party as we
build an argument for a reform of that
kind so i would say you know i'm better
doing what i'm doing um and i i'm
bringing some independence if you like
to the to the debate um and i think
that's what's needed uh and then the
labour front bench can uh can use that
so i i think there's an opportunity here
okay from honest i think the government
is about to make a major misstep if it
goes down the national insurance route
to fund social care there's a real
clear consensus actually that that would
be a very unfair way of doing it labor's
got an opportunity here to go bold on
social care and national care service
funded in the way that i described you
know with a modest contribution from
those who will benefit but wealth taxes
to supplement it that i think could
carry the country it's a big opportunity
for labour and that's my independent
advice to them this morning okay very
very quickly we're out of time so is
that a yes or a no if you were
approached you'd say no thanks quite
quite happy where i am kate i'm quite
happy where i am and i think it's it's
working working well so i i'd rather
stay stay doing what i'm doing why
wouldn't you be in god's own country
it's good to see you as always thank you
mr thank you thank you thank you